نبدا هذا اليوم من السودان حيث كشف
المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في السودان
خالد عمر يوسف عن تعذر توقيعه على اتفاق
نهائي في موعده بسبب عدم توافق اطراف
الاتفاق الايطالي على بعض القضايا وقال
المتحدث الى اجتماعا سيعقد اليوم في القصر
الرئاسي يضم والاطراف المدنيه
لتوقيع الاتفاق نهائي وكان المتحدث باسم
العمليه السياسيه اكد ان كل الاطراف
ستواصل الخيراتها في مناقشات جاده للتوصل
الى اتفاق
معنى من امام القصر الجمهوري في الخرطوم
مراسلنا طاهر المرضي الطاهر ما الذي تنكب
عليه اجتماعات اليوم لتجاوز تلك العقبات
التي حالت دون توقيع في موعده
نعم هذه هي مشاورات اللحظه الاخيره هذه هي
الاجتماعات التي
ستبدا في وضع النقاط على الحروف فيما يختص
بالجدول الزمني الجديد بعد ان تعثر
التوقيع على الاتفاق اليوم وهو اليوم الذي
كان قد حدد في وقت سابق اليوم هنالك
اجتماع لمجموعه من الذين يعكفون على
العمليه السياسيه سواء كان الموقين على
الاتفاق الايطالي او المكونه العسكري
والاليه الثلاثيه سيكون لديهم اجتماع هام
اليوم لاصدار جدول زمني جديد تستطيع ان
تلتزم به كل الاطراف فيما يغتص بتوقيع
الاتفاق النهائي الاعلان السياسي وكذلك
توقيت اخر للتوقيع الوثيقه الدستوريه
وتشكيل هياكل السلطه الانتقاليه هذه
الاجتماع اليوم اكدت فيه القوه الموقعة
لاتفاق الايطالي لاكتمال الاعلان السياسي
بشكل كامل القوه المدنيه هزيتها للتوقيع
حتى ولو كان هذا اليوم ولكنهم وجهوا
رسالتهم للمكونه العسكري لحسن هذه
الخلافات اذا هم يرمون بالكره في ملعب
المكون العسكري هنالك هذا
الخلاف في داخل المكون العسكري هو الذي
ادى الى هذا التاجير والقضيه تتعلق بدمج
قوات الدعم السريع والجداول الزمنيه لهذا
الموضوع وهنالك
مقترحات من الجيش السوداني ان تكون الفتره
الانتقاليه او فتره دمج القوات الدعم
السريع هي نفس الفتره الانتقاليه المقدره
بعامين ولكن الدعم السريعي يرى ان هذا
التوقيت لا يمكن ان يكون باعتبار ان عمليه
الدم دائما تحتاج الى وقت وتجارب اخرى
ايضا للتطبيق على تنفيذ هذه العمليه ولكن
ما نعلمه الان هذه المكونات العسكريه
تنقرض نقاشات مكثفه لتجاوز هذه العقبات
وهنالك محاولات جاده للخروج من هذه الازمه
حتى تستطيع او يستطيع السودان ان يقوم
بتكوين الهياكل الفتره الانتقاليه وتكوين
الحكومه يقودها
تستطيع ان تطلع بدورها في المرحله القادمه
اعتقد ان هذه الجهود الذي تبذل في هذا
الاطار تسير بشكل حثيث حتى تستطيع ان
تتخطى هذه العقبه وننتظر يمكن للاجتماع
اليوم ان يصدر جدول زمني يؤكد فيه انتهاء
الازمه او بشكل او باخر القرب من حسم
الخلافات العسكريه من امام القصر الجمهوري
في الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك